[Music]  daddy has told her to go listen young  lady  but a friend is nowhere to be seen so  how'd you become such a hot shot  actually walk through history i'm a  showman that's what i'm meant to do  to the seats with the clearest view  she's hooked to the silver screen do you  know who i am yeah do you know who my  girlfriend is robert scheissen  barbra streisand sam sand yeah like  sands like the ocean like herbicide sand  no but stray sand sand  but the film is a saddling ball this is  faith that brought us together  our rhodes took us here  [Music]  you're not my  do you really want to see my boobs  can i touch them  see you tomorrow  [Music]  [Applause]  i think it's weird that i hang out with  gary and his 15 year old friends all the  time  [Music]  i'm not gonna  [Music]  forget it's like you're not gonna forget  me  [Music]  okay  [Music]  action  [Music]  hello  [Music]  [Music]  you